virtual meeting of the licensing and
regulatory committee
today the 7th of august 2020
now first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use the
messaging or chat function
during the meeting unless it is to
report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
but if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask
questions by the chair please await your
turn
if you experience connection issues in
the first instance please turn off your
camera
if this does not work you can also turn
off all incoming video
these options are available under the
three dots in the central information
bar
i would like to remind everyone present
that the meeting will be
live the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting and
the public and press are not lawfully
excluded
so the introductions are we have kay
sanders the licensing officer
catherine greene licensing officer emma
richbelt assistant manager
food safety and licensing nigel dulu the
legal advisor
and karen sayer the government gov
government governance officer
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
i will now ask the governance officer to
roll call the members present
thank you chair members please can you
reply with good morning or
present when i call out your name
councillor brewster
president councillor penyong present
councillor flatman president councillor
geek
president councillor guthrie president
councillor muller present councillor
otton
morning council phillips
morning councillor pratt
morning councillor stringer good morning
that's everybody chair excellent thank
you very much indeed
declaration of interest by councillor
are there any declaration declarations
of interest
please use the hands up function if
there are councillor stringer thank you
yes chair i i'm a personal alcohol
license holder
thank you for that
moving on confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting held on the 5th of june
2020 are there any points regarding
accuracy of the minutes
none can i have a proposal please
for the minutes counselor muller happy
to propose
chair and councillor epping young
happy due second chair thank you very
much
so could you now um take a roll call on
vote on that please
thank you chair members please can you
reply with four against or abstain
councillor brewster
sorry um approve
councillor penyong
four councillor flatman four
councillor geek four councillor guthrie
four councillor muller four
councillor autumn four councillor
phillips
four councillor pratt school
councillor stringer
thank you chair that's carried so the
minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed and will be signed at the next
practicable opportunity to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
none receive chair questions from
councillors
none received so we now move on
to the um business of the day which is
the
uh licensing act 2003 statement of
licensing policy statutory
five yearly revision so can we ask kay
the licensing officer to introduce the
report please thank you
thank you chair this report refers to
policy setting under the licensing act
2003.
since november can i just stop you there
can i
i suppose if everybody comes off and
then we can see kay
reporting it if you can just close your
videos down for a moment i do beg your
pardon
do you want me to put my video on
because i'm a little my wi-fi is a
little bit
oh i could try
i thought it would be nice if we could
see you but if it that's right no it's
fine i'll try if it goes i'll turn it
off
all right then thank you sorry about
that i just thought it'd be nice if we
could see you
yeah okay can you see me
no i've got it on
keep going then okay i'll keep going
okay sorry i'll start again
this report refers to policy setting
under the licensing act 2003.
since november 2005 local licensing
authorities have been responsible for
functions
under the license in act 2003 including
issuing of licences and authorizations
for licensable activities
premises clubs events and individuals
section 5 of the licensed snack 2003
requires that the license licensing
authority shall determine
and publish a local statement of
licensing policy
relating to the discharge of its
licensing functions under the act
in 2020 the authority is due to revisit
the statement
that has been in effect since january
2016
and this report seeks the approval of
the first draft revision in order
that the statutory consultation period
may then convince on its content
this is a statutory function of the
licensing team has today
undertaken the necessary work within
existing resources and by working
together with partner authorities
the resource coordination of activity
and costs associated with the
consultation process
will be shared between the two districts
and wider wherever viable in general
terms the legislation aims to
secure full cost recovery of
administering licensing act
functions through fees payable for
licensed applications and ongoing
maintenance
the fee banding system and fee levels
are currently set by central government
by regulation
this will be the fifth edition of the
council statement of licensing policy
under the license in act 2003
the licensing team has the necessary
experience stakeholder contacts
and networking in place to ensure that a
wide and balanced consultation takes
place
the consultation will take place over a
minimum period of four weeks
through various channels and media a
joint notice may also be placed in the
local press as part of this engagement
process
adoption of the license in that 2003
statement of license and policy is a
functional reserve for full council
at this authority the recommendations
are
that the draft provision of the
licensing act 2003 statement of licence
and policy
document attached as appendix a be
approved
further that the relevant officers
proceed with the commencement of a
period of statutory consultation in
accordance with the license in that 2003
legislation and regulations
the committee is able to resolve this
matter
may i just note that there's a slight
error on appendix a
page 19 of appendix a and that's page 29
of the report
14.2.5 um has been deleted
um but the follow-on numbers haven't
been corrected but this will be amended
um before
the policy goes out for consultation
thank you chair
thank you for that that was picked up in
briefing by councillor muller for us
that's very helpful right um
does anybody have any points that you'd
like to be clarified by the
licensing officer and i'll quickly spin
through you councillor brewster
thank you madam chair um yeah i've just
got two
um queries um
on page 14 um
and there is it claims that uh
mid-southwest obviously has 123 parishes
but it says this is the most of any in
the in the districts of the county
districts
i'm not sure that is actually correct
because obviously now we've got east
suffolk and west suffolk alongside and i
suspect that they've got more
um parishes um
and then on page 18 under
para 3.1 uh m
uh just a clarification really it speaks
there about the
european union service directive
just wondering how that will stand with
with the brexit situation
yeah the officers respond to that can
people note i'll be going a to z rather
than hands up facility if you don't mind
please
yes thank you um as far as the european
goes um
the the statement policy
it runs as it is but if anything changes
we can
just carry on with what changes we don't
have to revisit the policy every time
and we can just revise every five years
so if there's anything has changed any
guidance changes
we run with that um so we don't have to
revisit the policy every time something
changes
thank you for that thank you for that
and the number of parishes
can we look into that yes i will
if if that's not correct i'll change it
before it goes out to consultation
thank you cancer epping young any
questions you did have your hand up
questions uh thank you chair yes uh
um uh counselor brewster's picked up
the first one uh but on the same page
uh what was originally
uh c race relations act
1976 and so forth i just wondered why
we have deleted that yeah i asked that
one at briefing and i think
we'll ask kate to give us the answer on
that because it's further down the page
isn't it okay can you give us a help on
that please
yes i can um it has been replaced with
the qualities act 2010
and that's just further down the page
yes okay
okay thank thank you cancer wrapping
young what i have one more please
please yes yes uh don't
bear with me one second
[Music]
i did mark up my document uh
so uh on page
19 um
uh 14.2.6 f
uh i'd just like it and unders to get a
clarification on what that actually
means
the the issue about the radio links and
the ring around phone system
what's involved with that
thank you um not all towns but some
sometimes
do have a system where they will radio
link or phone land if if somebody enters
the premise
um and they know they've been banned or
they've caused trouble
they will phone round to all the local
um premises just to let them know let
them you know make them aware of what's
going on
all right thank you thank you for that
cancer wrapping young councillor flatman
questions for the officer
uh none at present chair thank you um
council rotten can you put your hand
down i'll come to you in order very
shortly
um counselor geek i know mine have been
answered thank you very much
good we're all on the same page that's
interesting good thank you
um councillor muller uh none none at all
uh chair thank you
and now cancer often you obviously have
something thank you please
yeah um i too want to ask on the human
rights act and the race relations
act um so i'm pleased that we have an
answer on those
um the other thing is the heading says
on the equality analysis no implications
i'd just like to comment on that and the
other is
a line to the council's policies so
i'm assuming that this would align with
any equality policies
and environmental policies and
at 16.3
little c um and i think that's
actually shown somewhere else the need
to show
evidence of residents in the uk
or ability to work in the uk um
would that be connected to our council's
um stance on modern slavery
um okay can you give us an answer on
that please
yes chair um the equalities we do
the equality uh impact assessment and we
send it through to the equalities team
and i have signed that off so we we are
meeting everything that's required
um um
sorry could you just so can you say what
the last what was the last point
it was um 16.3
um i'd have to run right through it now
but
there is a couple of times where it
states
that people must state
that they have a right to work
yes and under the act it's under the
licensing act they have to give evidence
of their right to work i.e a passport a
residence permit birth certificate
um any individual applicant um we'll
have to do that
so what i'm really just trying to
confirm is that obviously
that would comply with the council's
stance
on opposing um modern slavery
or that issue i don't think that's not
the reason that we ask what we ask for
it under the act
um it's purely their right to work
nigel can you give just a further bit of
guidance on that for us please
yes chair um there is statutory
obligations on on
all employers and local authorities um
to
to comply with with legislation there is
other legislation relating
obviously to um modern slavery
um so there is a background legislation
that we would need to follow and
obviously our policies are in line with
that
so you don't feel that that would need
to be written in this policy document
no because it it is the law um it would
be illegal
to to to have any policy that um
in any way permits that okay
thank you very much thank you councillor
otton
councillor phillips
no questions from me thank you thank you
councillor pratt
no questions from me thank you
councillor stringer
thank you chair uh yeah just one
question do we
need any lining here regarding
emergency legislation uh given the
situation we're in now
we see licensed premises where people
within them are breaking the law
uh and how do we deal with that because
at the moment
they're just up for a fine what they're
not doing is
is endangering their licence and frankly
if you're running a licensed premises
and you're seating people too close
together and people aren't socially
distancing i would suggest you're
running an unruly house and therefore
your license should be at risk
either k or um nigel if you could answer
that for us please
uh i think we did we did um talk about
this yesterday
and you did yeah yeah covered 19 would
come under
um risk assessments because they have to
do risk assessments
um and the police do liaise with us if
there's any issues with regard to
breaking covert legislation um
which has a knock-on effect on on the
license nigel i don't know whether you
can
expand on that no that's right chair
um obviously there is a raft of um
legislation that's recently been brought
in which gives local authorities
uh powers to ensure compliance with that
um
and obviously that that the policy uh
health and safety stance would align
with those
okay so so the there is that that
legislation already exists and it's
already in place that's brilliant thank
you
thank you yeah thank you for your
question counselor stringer we did
discuss that yesterday and
it's a very valid point to be brought
out so that it can be seen that we
are looking at these points thank you
very much indeed
um so um i now open the item up for
debate
regarding the paper that we have we've
had questions of the officers
and i'll just run through you all again
if i may please if you wish to
um comment further or whatever counselor
brewster
nothing at the moment
uh nothing at the moment chair thank you
um councillor flatman no nothing at the
moment chair thank you
myself um i think all the points have
been raised quite eloquently
uh councillor muller uh none at this
stage thank you chair
councillor otton nothing to add
council supports thank you skip
councillor geek
i beg your pardon counseling
that's that's absolutely fine i have
nothing to add at the moment
well we say at the moment i'm going to
go for a proposal a second or shortly so
um counselor geek we've done that yes um
i've forgotten where i've gone now um
councillor phillips wasn't it yes
nothing from me thank you
and councillor pratt nothing to add
thank you
councillor stringer regarding the paper
yeah can i just thank the officers for a
very clear
well-written paper uh good i'll be sub
and i'll be supporting it thank you
well um i will be looking for a proposal
and a second or if nobody wishes to
comment further
you can use your hands up whoa that went
quick
counseling bullet and happy to propose
the recommendations here
thank you very much indeed and
councillor epinyong
are happy to second the proposal chair
thank you
and that was very appropriate councillor
stringer to thank the officers for the
report
um so with that in mind uh can i ask
um the
role call to be made of the outcome of
the vote please
and let's just be clear uh so we get
there
it's the recommendation on our paper or
it's
um the recommendation that the draft
revision licensing act 2003 statement of
licensing policy document
attached as appendix a b approved
further that the relevant
officers proceed with the commencement
of the period of statutory consultation
in accordance with the licensing act of
2003 legislation and regulations
and the committee is able to resolve
this matter would we put a date on this
please nigel can you just advise us on
that
uh would you meet update from will it be
done from
today or or do the officers have to um
do
do they need a lead in time of a few
working days or what from this
resolution
i would go with the licensing officers
on that but i presume that the date
would be from the date of
approval by the committee
[Music]
right so it will be as from today's date
i presume then
uh so with that in mind can we go to the
vote then please
thank you chair members please can you
reply with four against or abstain
councillor gerard brewster four
councillor paul eppenyong or
councillor julie flatman a four
councillor helen geek four
councillor kathy guthrie four
councillor david muller four
councillor pennyotton four
thank you chair that's carried unanimous
well thank you very much indeed and
thank you everyone
for the content and for the debate today
so
i'll now formally close the meeting if i
may please thank you very much indeed
you